okay well you clearly don't care so why
don't you just leave i would like to
stay this pertains to me i would like
you to leave why don't you go outside
and take a shot of insulin and have a
nap okay why do you always assume i have
diabetes you have a glass of apple juice
and tell me that you don't have diabetes
okay
all right see just the noise you made
when you stood up i could
this guy doesn't just want to win you
know he wants to bury you he wants to
humiliate you and he wants to prove to
the world
how long is this gonna take i'm like a
quarter of the way through
hey if sabre truly cared about a
long-term well-being they would set up
hand desanitizing stations hold up
what's a hand desanitizing station it's
a bowl of dirt
okay
you understand
oh my god
that's a good improvement okay you
understand
the more we expose ourselves to germs
the stronger
[Laughter]
attend the tale of sweeney todd
he gets shoot
i forgot it all right
here we go right away hey you
yeah give me our biggest client on the
phone asmb
um you can't do that
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you don't really toss the dough
try to destroy the old ways gabe i will
not let you do it
[Laughter]
we're gonna go outside and i guarantee
you you can get out oh are you okay
how's the camera
did you just sms text message me i just
came from the museum where i saw an
exhibit
hey
did your sms text message me i just came
from the museum we're a heist
return to sender
clean up on l5
[Laughter]
don't make me pre-fire you you wouldn't
dare
oh man and when i get promoted you're
full fired if you get promoted ah
don't make me pre-fire you you wouldn't
dare you're pre-fired and when i'm
promoted you're full fired if you're
promoted
oh it's just like the old days
i'm working on an english character
would you mind
it's called reginald pufta and
come on
come on
sorry mate
i forgot make me snotted crane
this is no good i'm not even a real
actor let me out
do you want your life to be better
or worse or to stay the same get out of
my way
look at
[Laughter]
me congrats wow
congratulations
that was good right
we don't recycle
we don't
why have i been separating trash into
whites and colors
[Laughter]
uh could you please show them into
conference room b
i'll be right with you the
pharmaceutical meeting should be able to
move you know they should be able to
accommodate us
i thought he was going to show us into
conference room b
she took him with him
i thought she was talking to the
cameraman
camera lady
so have you chosen a leader yet
so broad
cool
don't look at me
i still want to quit
but if i quit we'll all quit it'll be
anarchy
[Music]
i still want to quit
but if i quit
we'll all quit
i still want to quit
but if i quit we'll all quit it'll
does this even work
that guy um
we're looking for him which way did he
go this way this way this way
that guy when he leave which way did he
go look for him
we
looking for him he went that way i'm
sorry
we're looking for him which way did he
go who knows this way this way this way
this way i don't know which way
sorry sorry
sorry
the mall is corrupt molly's evil their
appearances
jim that is so inappropriate
you guys like the chat absolutely get
these done out out
hello hey
here to talk about woof oh is that cool
yes definitely as long as you're here to
tell me i'm a billionaire you're
on your way man on your way
sorry
oh no it's great i love working at
dunder mifflin taliban branch
bloop
it's great oh
oh oh no it's great hello we're going to
dunder mifflin
we have three sex
or heavy petting closets one
masturbation closet
does anyone have a problem with that
yes gay closet five that wasn't like
five clutches no that's that wasn't the
problem three heavy petting closets one
masturbation closet and one gay class no
absolutely yes
no problem everybody happy with the
glory holes
what
well i heard about it somewhere holy
fifth closet will have a glory hole
[Laughter]
guys
sorry
we actually love musical theater
can i just notice that you're
like in the last one it's really funny
we actually love musical theater
the great thing about stephen
oh she's hard to grab hang on that's
what she said
okay who can tell me i'm sorry i'm sorry
did you laugh
oh i should get the accident report
binder i've never used a gun von born
ever we can before
what did you just say
toby toby get back in here right now i
said you get the action report founder
because he finished toby is
great group back there too uh
holly and
mindy
you